or not of tragedy and destruction
injustice to begins in a fractured
universe where bonds are broken and
every alliance is thrown into war
injustice to opens in the wake of the
dismantled Justice League as Batman and
Superman clash for control but the war
has only just begun
I am Brainiac
as the expansive storyline on poles will
battle your way across the DC Universe
and the decisions you make will have
earth-shattering consequences
[Music]
injustice to has a massive roster of
characters each playable and fighting
for their cause allow me to give you a
proper demonstration join forces with
Superman and fight fire with fire with
allies like Robin Wonder Woman cyborg
and Black Adam you wield devastating
power
[Music]
unite with the Dark Knight and fight
alongside Harley Quinn Black Canary and
a coalition of freedom fighters one more
did you
quivers not empty yet
sometimes it's better to be bad battle
alongside gorilla grodd society with
Catwoman Bane Captain Cold
and other mercenaries no wonder Brainiac
wants you dead or alive Oh Jordan or go
it alone there are plenty of wild cards
in the mix Supergirl Swamp Thing and
dozens of other characters including the
mastermind himself great who you choose
to enter the arena with is only the
beginning
injustice two introduces gear custom
equipment that allows you to alter the
abilities and look of your favorite
characters am I making you look bad as
in
every battle brings the opportunity to
earn new gear from useful stat augments
to impressive special moves and
abilities injustice to Zee air system is
an invaluable element of the game
experience
there's a whole world beyond the massive
story campaign the multiverse is
designed for players that need a new
challenge each multiverse contains
modifiers that change the way to game
plays as you climb up the ladder the
challenge increases and so do the
rewards
multiverses are always changing hourly
daily and weekly challenges all present
new opportunities to grow your
characters and earn brand-new gear
you'll regret this but beating you is so
fun
join a guild with friends or other
players to further your experience and
earn exclusive rewards through daily and
weekly challenges
[Music]
whether you've joined a guild to gain
experience faster or to dominate the
leaderboards with an elite crew you'll
find that victory through collaboration
proves to be exponentially more
satisfying
no more mr. Boy Scout with injustice to
mobile the arena is always at your
fingertips complete with the cinematic
storyline from the console version of
the game Smackdown fight like never
before with a brand new dynamic fighting
system employed jumps ducks and
projectile attacks as you battle your
way through endless challenges character
shards give you a new way to play
raising your level and unlocking unique
character talents this dreams complete
the right challenges and you leave an
unlock tier for the console version of
the game with all of the characters
action and gear available on console
the injustice to mobile experience is
the perfect way to keep the fight alive
[Music]
the war ahead an injustice to bears
immense consequences now is the time to
seize true power shape your battle and
dominate the competition
you